en parlait justement pierre laurin
journaliste écrivain spécialiste de la
russie auteur de livres ukraine une
histoire entre deux destins nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau pierre laurin
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on va peut-être revenir
sur le discours pour commencer du
président emmanuel macron il a notamment
un soutenu l'offre de vladimir poutine
pour une réunion on conseil de sécurité
de l'onu comment est ce que on peut
comprendre cette proposition de la
dîmière poutine je crois que pour
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui la
situation est mûre pour faire des
avancées diplomatiques
c'est le 75e anniversaire de la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale cela va être
fêté en grande pompe à moscou le 9 mai
prochain avec une brochette de chefs
d'état qui ont décidé de faire le
déplacement ce qui n'était pas le cas
les années précédentes il y aura
évidemment macron il y aura certainement
une trempe et là se situe en fait la clé
pour comprendre ce que veut faire la
lumière poutine aujourd'hui la réunion
du conseil de sécurité des cinq pays
vainqueur parce qu'en fait c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit ce sont les cinq pays
vainqueur de la seconde guerre mondiale
qui vont peut-être essayer de déterminer
quels sont les risques aujourd'hui
notamment l'iran essayé de renouer un
dialogue éventuel parce que la situation
en iran aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
malgré les apparences beaucoup plus
favorable que précédemment parce que le
principal fauteur de guerre
c'est à dire le général souleymane sy a
disparu d'une certaine manière la frappe
américaine a rendu un énorme service aux
ayatollahs qui était pris entre le
marteau des sanctions américaines et
l'enclume dessus lémanique ne voulait
rien entendre de dunes d'un discours
pacificateur donc les choses deviennent
beaucoup plus clair et le fait de
vouloir impliquer les cinq pays et
éventuellement d'autres vainqueurs de la
seconde guerre mondiale parce qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui ont qui ont participé
et qui ont contribué au combat
c'est à dire essayer de renouer avec
l'esprit de la grande alliance de
l'époque et je crois que c'est ça le
principal objectif de la dmr poutine et
macron il souscrit emmanuel macron y
souscrit parce qu'il est dans la logique
de faire rentrer la russie dans la
grande famille des des peuples
occidentaux parce que c'est vrai rien
depuis ce matin tous les chefs d'état
qui sont intervenus nous invite à nous
souvenir nous souvenir pour ça ne
recommence pas cette horreur
on a entendu des descriptions assez
glaçant tout ce qui a pu être vécue
l'importance de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme le racisme aujourd'hui
le président vladimir poutine l'a
rappelé on a bien entendu en tête le
conflit israélo palestinien et les
paroles de benyamin nétanyahou lors de
son discours il a appelé à agir contre
les tyrans de téhéran qu'elle est
qu'elle peut être la diplomatie russe
justement dans ce conflit là pour
apaiser la diplomatie russe depuis de
très nombreuses années
elle essaye d'avoir un rôle de médiateur
de facilitateur de solutions c'est grâce
à la diplomatie russe que l'accord qui a
été dénoncée par les américains l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien a été conclu il
a été dénoncé ensuite par le président
tron mais il était le fruit d'un large
consensus réalisé notamment grâce à la
médiation russe sont les russes qui ont
permis cela par ailleurs la présence
russe dans de très nombreux endroits de
2,2 de la zone les bons rapports avec
israël
les bons rapports avec la turquie les
bons rapports avec l'arabie saoudite les
bons rapports avec l'egypte
le soutien en demi teinte de
de l'homme fort de libye et star tout
cela fait que la russie aujourd'hui dans
cette zone occupe une position centrale
qu'aucun autre pays ne peut lui
contester
et donc elle détient les clés qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir aujourd'hui de la
relation justement entre israël et la
russie depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale alors pendant toute la
période soviétique
israël est l allié des états unis
donc il était l'adversaire de l'union
soviétique
les choses ont changé à partir de 1991
et particulièrement de très bons
rapports se sont établies entre les
présidents russe
yalcin puis poutine et l'état d'israël
les différents dirigeants de l'état
d'israël parce que eux sans s'en rendre
compte la russie a renoué avec une
vieille tradition saristes qui était la
protection des chrétiens d'orient des
communautés orthodoxes bien sûr mais en
généralisant tous les chrétiens d'orient
se trouvait placé sous une certaine
protection de la russie et la russie à
renouer avec cela c'est à dire que pour
protéger les chrétiens de syrie où des
chrétiens du liban
la russie intervient auprès des
dirigeants de ces pays de manière à là
encore faciliter les choses et de ce
point de vue là la politique d'israël
correspond à ce que israël attend de la
russie c'est à dire à la fois un soutien
à la fois quelqu'un qui est là pour
veiller au grain et pour éviter les
problèmes et il ya une chose qui est
caractéristique c'est que chaque fois
qu'israël s'est sentie menacée par la
présence iranienne en syrie et que
israël à lancer des frappes contre des
positions iraniennes en syrie la russie
a laissé faire et ne s'est jamais élevée
contre une frappe israélienne contre des
positions iraniennes en suède
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir alors cette
fois ci des relations plus personnelle
un qu'entretiennent vladimir poutine et
benyamin nétanyahou conseil se sont
rencontrés à de très nombreuses reprises
oui ils se voient très fréquemment je
crois qu'il ya une certaine estime
réciproque parce que ce sont des
dirigeants qui qui ont à coeur leur pays
je crois que c'est ça qu'il est qui les
unit c'est à dire que il ils savent quel
va être le discours de l'autre et quelle
va être la position de l'autre et donc
cela permet des rapprochements à ce
qu'on sait quelles concessions
on est prêt à faire et on se comprend
alors que des dirigeants qui sont moins
affirmée bien il y à la place à la
discussion aux malentendus et donc ça ne
le courant ne peut pas passer avec
netanyahu
le courant passe et en règle générale
lorsqu'il y a un problème
netanyahu va à moscou pour expliquer
pour prévenir pour trouver une solution
et les solutions sont généralement
trouvait alors on a vécu ce matin en
direct sur rt france l'inauguration d'un
monument à la mémoire des défenseurs de
leningrad à jérusalem pourquoi il était
important pour israël
justement que cette inauguration et lieu
aujourd'hui en présidence en présence
bien évidemment de vladimir poutine
la chaire consent s'y prêtait poutine
était là donc c'était l'occasion rêvée
d'un autre côté il est clair que bon là
nous sommes dans un dans un conflit de
grille de lecture entre la vision
occidentale et la vision russe de la
seconde guerre mondiale chacun a sa
vision et israël a une vision qui est
partagée qui est commune c'est à dire
qu'israël est comment dirais-je
reconnaissante à l'armée soviétique
d'avoir libéré
et quand il ya une reconnaissance qui
est normal et l'est également et
l'adoptent principalement le
le point de vue occidental sur la
lecture de la seconde guerre mondiale et
donc il y à un point d'eux un point
central un point de rapprochement des
deux des deux points de vue et ce qui
est très clair c'est que pour vladimir
poutine ce qui ne peut pas admettre
aujourd'hui c'est que on ne
reconnaissent pas à sa juste valeur
l'apport de la russie de l'union
soviétique dans la victoire de la
seconde guerre mondiale parce qu'on se
souvient effectivement l'absence du
président en jeu l'avenir qu'il n'avait
pas été conviée en juin dernier sur les
plages de normandie pour la cérémonie du
10 ds que cette journée elle permet pas
aussi bas de ne pas oublier certains
pans de l'histoire qu'on a oublié ou pas
volontairement ou pas vous aimez vous le
dire en occident je crois qu'en occident
on est un tout petit peu dans l'auto
dans l'auto célébration c'est à dire bon
on tout tourne autour du débarquement
c'est vrai que le débarquement a été une
date fondamentale pour la victoire
une date est essentielle mais il ne faut
pas oublier qu'au moment où vous les
gi's débarqué avec d'autres pays dont
les britanniques et puis un groupe
français qui s'est illustré d'ailleurs
débarqué en normandie en juin 44 les
soviétiques étaient pratiquement déjà
aux portes de berlin il avait gagné la
guerre
ceux qui restaient à libérer de l'europe
occidentale effectivement les américains
avec l'appui des alliés l'ont fait
mais lorsque les la jonction s'est fait
entre liddes les troupes américaines et
des troupes soviétiques
c'était sur l'elbe bien au delà de
berlin et ça c'était en mai 45 c'est à
dire 11 mois après le débarquement donc
le débarquement c'est capital mais c'est
à la fin il est beaucoup plus important
je crois de souligner le fait qu' il y a
eu une résistance très
vivre de la part des alliés occidentaux
en afrique
en italie des 43 en sicile le
débarquement de sicile etc
mais ça on le commémore pas pour des
raisons qui sont à ceux relativement
mystérieuse on se focalise sur le guider
mais effectivement à juste raison parce
que c'était l'opération la plus
magistrale et et qu'ils attendent qu'ils
étaient et fait la malle le le plus
grand débarquement qui est été réussie
de toute l'histoire de l'humanité donc
effectivement c'est marquant mais en
même temps tout l'avancée de l'armée
soviétique jusqu'à berlin elle est un
peu passée sous silence
avec la libération de tout un tas de
capital libération qui s'est ensuite
transformé c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
en parle très peu en une occupation de
troupes soviétiques
mais ça c'est une autre un autre pan de
l'histoire on en prenant la guerre
froide alors il ya quelques minutes lors
de son discours emmanuel macron a
justement parlé de la vaillante 1 il a
qualifié la vaillante armée rouge qui a
un libérer le camp d'auschwitz a aussi
une journée pour se souvenir de cette
libération là je vous propose on va y
revenir dans quelques instants mais je
vous propose avant d'écouter le
président vladimir poutine justement qui
s'exprimait ce matin lors de
l'inauguration d'un monument
je vous propose de l'écouter le monument
que nous avons inauguré aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le monument de notre
mémoire en commun et les représentants
de la communauté israélienne de nos
compatriotes des anciens combattants
tout cela personne ne peut rester
indifférent indifférence là il ya eu un
investissement financier et je tiens à
exprimer notre gratitude à l'état
d'israël de voir sans sa contribution
pour rendre hommage
à ceux qui ont souffert en urss pendant
la guerre dans ce pays où vivent
beaucoup de d'anciens combattants de
cette guerre au nombre de 4000 et ici
comme en russie on connaît l'importance
des leçons du passé et nous ne
permettrons pas que le monde oublie ce
sacrifice
cette douleur et ne permettront pas la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme de
chauvinisme etc
et c'est une leçon pour les générations
qui vont nous suivre et c'est un hommage
ce monument en fait un hommage à ceux
qui nous ont offert la vie qui nous ont
permis de survivre
donc voila c'était lors du discours du
président vladimir poutine ce matin lors
de l'inauguration d'un monument à la
mémoire des défenseurs de leningrad
pierre laurent c'est une plaie qui est
encore béante
aujourd'hui l'occupation ni graal la
résistance de la riviera ii ling
rappelle la blocage a duré neuf cent
jours et leningrad n'est pas tombé
c'était d'ailleurs l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles l'offensive de la
wehrmacht n'a pas réussi parce que tant
que le verrou de leningrad
tenez il était très difficile de
déployer des troupes de déployer les
lignes de maintenance très loin à
l'intérieur de la russie et c'est ce qui
a permis le sursaut soviétique et à
partir de stalingrad de la bataille de
stalingrad
le reflux maintenant c'est toujours un
souvenir qui est très vif parce qu'il y
a eu des millions de morts
saleh
on estime à entre 20 et 27 millions le
nombre de morts soviétique pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est de loin le
plus grand contributeur de de la
thanatologie si j'ose dire
c'était cet effroyable n'y a pas une
famille soviétique qui n'a eu un ou
plusieurs dans le président russe lui
même a été directement touchées on l'a
senti il était très ému d'ailleurs les
mains sur son frère est décédé au moment
de cette époque il est normand il
il est très touché par tout cela et
d'ailleurs ça se sent la manière dont
depuis quelques semaines il se dresse
contre les tentes ce qu'il appelle les
tentatives de réécrire l'histoire c'est
parce que ça le touche profondément et
puis en même temps bon le peuple
soviétique a conscience d'avoir
contribué plus que de raison à la
victoire et on le considère un peu comme
un parent pauvre
je crois que là pour pour les rues c'est
une injustice et pas seulement pour les
russes d'ailleurs mais bon maintenant ce
qui est très claire aujourd'hui c'est
que vladimir poutine est heureux de
cette reconnaissance
et lorsqu'il dit que il propose
lorsqu'il propose une réunion pour
régler les problèmes
c'est quelque part une manière de dire
on efface tout et on recommence sur de
meilleures bases
je crois que aujourd'hui contrairement à
l'année dernière où il y encore au
moment de l'élection de deux
donald trump aux états unis les les clés
sont entre ses mains parce qu'ils
disposent maintenant de plusieurs alliés
européens est l'un des plus importants
de ces alliés et emmanuel macron qui est
sur la même longueur d'onde que lui
je crois que ce qui est important pour
vladimir poutine
c'est de parvenir à sortir de la logique
où les événements d'ukraine ont enfermé
l'europe et par delà l'europe le monde
occidental pour dresser pour construire
éventuellement quelque chose de nouveau
merci beaucoup pierre loin d'avoir
partagé votre analyse en direct sur
notre plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste écrivain spécialiste de la
russie et notamment auteur du livre
ukraine une histoire entre deux destins
publié aux éditions bar culte merci
merci beaucoup